you've all heard about Facebook's recent
problems protecting people's personal
information huge story it's been ongoing
well a lot of apps and websites are
updating their Terms of Service I'm
talking about the terms that users must
accept before using an app now most
people just click agree and they don't
read the fine print on what they're
agreeing to they just want to use the
app they're probably not aware of what
they've agreed to so as a public service
we're gonna look at a few right now this
is just to help you out for example you
should know this Twitter
when you click agree on Twitter you
agree that the opinions of mentally ill
strangers are the guiding principle in
your life that's what you're agreeing to
the food delivery app post mates
if you click agree on post mates you
agree that you are definitely too high
to drive to Wendy's right now real HBO
streaming app HBO GO when you click
agree on HBO GO you agree to always
think fondly about the ex whose password
you're using yeah uber when you click
agree on uber you agree to be audible
gar be with the weight loss app
MyFitnessPal if you click agree on
MyFitnessPal you agree to use this app
only once then feel ashamed every time
you see it yeah we've all been there the
music discovery apps Shazam when you
click agree on Shazam you agree to
constantly ruin parties by holding up
your phone and saying it's not getting
it
the handyman apt TaskRabbit
when you click agree on TaskRabbit you
agree that you were not a real man and
if this guy ends up banging your wife
well you deserve it
snapchat snapchat when you click agree
on snapchat you agree that you are a
fourteen-year-old girl slash 53 year old
undercover cop and finally lift when you
click agree on lift you agree that every
time you use the app you'll say out loud
please be Alexis please be Alexis Nissan
Versa again
[Applause]
you